c'est l'une des 30 monique collange
député du tarn n'a pas hésité à apporter
sa signature au texte d'arnaud
montebourg
pour elle il ne s'agit pas d'un débat
partisan mais d'abord d'une question de
principe
n'importe quel citoyen qui a fait une
bêtise à un moment donné sa ville est
poursuivi et jusqu'au bout donc il ya
pas de raison que quand on est élu on
passe à travers et en plus quand on est
père vienne le représentant de la france
des français
ce matin tous les députés ont découvert
dans leur boîte aux lettres
ce petit livre blanc un texte de 93
pages signée arnaud montebourg une
proposition pour la mise en accusation
de jacques chirac devant la haute cour
de justice pour entamer la procédure il
faut 58 signature l'assemblée nationale
déjà trente députés de la majorité
plurielle approuve 19 d'entre eux ont
l'étiquette socialiste
de quoi embarrasser la direction du
parti
nous considérons qu'il ne revient pas au
parti socialiste groupe socialiste de
metz jacques chirac en accusation devant
la haute cour ou une région que tous les
français comprennent cela paraîtrait en
période de cohabitation comme une
manoeuvre politicienne
la proposition montebourg intervient
alors que la justice a renoncé à se
prononcer sur les infractions impliquant
le président le juge patrick desmure en
charge de l'enquêté sur les emplois
fictifs de la ville de paris a jeté
l'épongé premier dans l'autre volet
judiciaire celui des marchés des hlm de
la capitale le juge eric halphen s'est
déclaré à son tour incompétent que ces
démarches soient judiciaires ou
politique aux yeux du rpr il s'agit
d'abord d'une manoeuvre en vue de la
présidentielle les socialistes ont
choisi de placer leur campagne sur une
attaque personnelle et si possible
salissantes de la part du président à un
public allant c'est un système
l'hypocrite à double je me suis juste un
jour ils bons apôtres
mais il
il lâche monsieur hollande a fait son
petit numéro et aujourd'hui c'est
monsieur montebourg et le député
socialiste de promettre des jaf une
deuxième vague de signatures
mais la complexité de la procédure comme
l'obligation d'obtenir un vote de
l'assemblée du sénat font que la
proposition montebourg on risque fort de
rester lettre morte
pas seulement des juges français mais
juges européens